à aux etats unis une sphère
politico-médiatique qui suscite la
polémique
un animateur de la chaîne fox news
affirme avoir été surveillé par la nfl
des accusations qui ont contraint agence
à réagir mais la polémique continue
d'enfler pour plus de précision on
retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
bruce coiffe tout va alors tout d'abord
qui est ce fameux animateur que à qui on
reproche donc et que lui reproche-t-on
concrètement bonsoir stéphanie alors
tucker carlson c'est l'animateur vedette
de la chaîne foxnews il est à l'antenne
tous les soirs à 20h pour une tranche
qui réuni en moyenne 3 millions de
téléspectateurs ce qu'ils ont fait
l'émission la plus regardée parmi toutes
les chaînes d'informations ici aux etats
unis
tucker carlson c'est un peu le porte
voix des conservateurs il se montre très
critique contre les démocrates et donc
le 28 juin dernier il affirme à
l'antenne qu'un lanceur d'alert l'a
averti qu'il était surveillé par la
haine et c'est qu'ils chercheraient à
faire fuiter des informations sur
l'animateur sur toker carlson donc afin
de faire déprogrammer son émission cette
déclaration a provoqué une très vive
polémique avec d'abord d'un côté ceux
qui se sont offusqués de possibles
agissements la sorte de la part de
l'année c'est puis de l'autre ceux qui
n'ont pas vraiment cru les affirmations
de tucker carlson affirmant qu'ils
étaient en train de mentir pour créer le
buzz mais la polémique a pris une telle
ampleur que finalement c'est la haine
essai qui a pris position publiquement
ce qui est très rare elle a publié un
communiqué sur son compte twitter pour
démentir formellement les accusations de
stocker car houston écouter cette
allégation et foster carlson n'a jamais
été une cible de nos services il a aimé
ça n'a jamais eu pour projet d' essayer
de retirer son émission de l'antenne et
malgré ce démenti d'un essai de
nouvelles révélations ont été faites ces
dernières heures thomas avec un nouvel
et
mon velimir poutine oui voilà de
nouvelles informations qui ont émergé
ces dernières heures ici aux etats unis
tucker karlsson a affirmé qu'il avait
été surveillé par cette agence de
renseignement parce qu'il prévoyait de
réaliser une interview avec vladimir
poutine et que pour cela ils étaient en
lien avec des entremetteurs des
intermédiaires pour pouvoir pouvoir
caler justement cette interview avec le
président russe selon l'animateur de fox
news line et c'est voulait justement
mettre en évidence des liens entre lui
et ses fameuses intermédiaire us pour le
faire passer pour quelqu'un de déloyale
voire un agent de l'étranger et le
contenu des emails de tucker carlson
c'est encore une fois lui qui
l'affirment ce contenu de ces mails
auraient circulé auprès d'un certain
nombre de journalistes à washington avec
son nom donc ce ne n'était pas des mails
anonymes il ya des informations qui ont
également été publiées sur le site
axios qui a demandé une nouvelle
réaction à la nsa avec ces nouvelles
informations la nsn n'a pas souhaité
réagir se contentant du communiqué
qu'elle avait déjà publié donc pour
démentir ces affirmations alors du côté
de tucker carlson on affirme qu'il y à
une instrumentalisation des services de
renseignements à des fins politiques
écoutez ce qu'il a déclaré c'était hier
soir ici aux etats-unis sur foxnews
on ne peut pas avoir des services de
renseignements utilisés comme des
instruments de contrôle politique
les deux parties étaient d'accord là
dessus les démocrates étaient
particulièrement inflexibles là dessus
plus maintenant à prévoir une interview
avec le président russe vladimir poutine
ne pourrait pas justifier en soi d'être
surveillés par les services de
renseignement et surtout pas à ce que
son nom soit divulgué de la sorte il
faut rappeler aussi que la chaîne nbc
news a réalisé une interview avec
vladimir poutine s'était dit à moins
d'un mois en marge de sa rencontre avec
le président américain joe biden alors
pour toker carson et les conservateurs
il faut rendre des comptes il demande
des comptes de la part des autorités
compétentes et surtout il estime qu'il
s'agit d'une nouvelle illustration d'une
possible instrumentalisation des
institutions à des fins politiques par
l'administration démocrate
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington